[Music]
Mandy is with us in Kansas City welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show Mandy how are
you I'm great how are you better than I
deserve what's up so I have a question
we my husband and I have been kind of on
your plan since May so we read your
Total Money Makeover book got super
excited got ready paid off you know
within the first 90 days are like 6,000
dollars but the problem is every time we
pay off a debt we do a huge victory lap
and take a while to come back to it what
do you suggest on how to avoid that we
don't have a good support system in fact
my dad thinks we're absolutely nut to
make fun of us about it but we just need
some guidance and some help
what's your dad have you got not telling
your home 57000 okay and by a huge
victory lap you mean you just kind of
stopped doing your budget and you don't
go into debt again but you just stop
making progress
correct okay and what's your household
income and we make about a hundred
thousand why are you getting out of debt
because after paying child support and
daycare we find ourselves just
completely maxed out and we want to be
able to eventually get me home with the
kids but because it's it's drowning us
okay well you should be debt-free in two
years would that get you home with the
kids
yes okay do you need to put pictures of
your kids on your budget that's a good
idea I mean you need to do something to
remind you of your why don't you yes
because what's happening is is your
short-term pleasures are taking away
your long-term
sole enriching activity which is being
home with your kids in other words you
know your
you're giving up the best thing out
there for some stupid little stuff on
the short-term because you're why is not
in front of you in your emotions am i
right
yes even though we see them every day we
still don't know somehow you got it so
now you got to relate sticking to the
budget and living on beans and rice -
how fast I get to be home with the kids
over and over and over and over again
that's a really noble big why and if you
got a big why you can do all kinds of
stuff you know why don't make you run
through a wall you know and what's
happening is you're disconnecting why
you're doing this and so you're
unwilling to pay the short-term price to
get the long-term gain is that logical
and that that's where the disconnect is
so if you can fix that disconnect then I
think you're gonna see a huge movement
in this and you that'll keep you back on
track back on track in other words
here's an extreme okay let's say that
your child had a rare disease they don't
okay but I'm just making up a bizarre
thing to illustrate my point okay and
you had to be debt-free in order to buy
the vaccine to save their life within
two years and we'd be doing it yeah that
would be it that would be like the
largest possible y on the planet right
yeah you you would not get off track
would you no we wouldn't
now and let's see that's my that's I'm
illustrating the point with a bizarre
hyperbole but just the same it still it
makes the point if you get a big enough
y going then it doesn't matter what
anybody else thinks it doesn't matter
whether you got a support group it
doesn't matter if you dot dot dot it
doesn't matter if dot dot dot we're
gonna get it done anyway it doesn't
matter if we lose our job it doesn't
matter if the car breaks down it doesn't
matter if the kid gets the flu it
doesn't matter if Johnny breaks his arm
we're stinking getting out of that you
know we're gonna do it anyway nothing is
gonna knock us off track
we may get knocked off track but we're
gonna get right back up because we got
to do it because our Y or Y is so big
and so worth
and that's living like no one else so
that later you can live and give like no
one else so somehow we you know you and
your husband almost need to record a
message to yourself that that starts
playing you know on your phone ever so
often just to remind you that the reason
you're doing this the reason you're
doing this the reason you're doing this
it's worth the sacrifice the Bible says
no discipline seems Pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
no one enjoys the process you're going
through we just do it because the result
is worth it right right and that's what
you're after so I think that's what the
two of you need to sit down and somehow
I would need visual reminders around me
audio reminders around me you know put
pictures of the kids on the refrigerator
like they're on the milk carton I don't
know I don't know we got it we got to do
something here because I think for me
you wanting to be there full-time with
them is a big motivator if you'll keep
it in front of you it'll keep you on
track that I missed something no you did
not okay that's how I would go about it
you got out of the father why the what
will come to you the how will come to
you if the why is important enough hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]